The fundamental story of
genesis is something like this.
Yeah,
and it's perhaps the most brilliant
contribution of Judeo Christian thought to
world history.
It's,
it's total impact is
virtually in calculable.
The idea is this,
that chaos can be conceptualized as
something that has an essentially feminine
aspect as a matrix and a matrix is a
structure from which other structures
emerge and the story of genesis
makes the hypothesis that logos,
which is the word of God,
a phenomenon associated with
speech and communication and logic,
logos,
logic,
rationality,
courage,
exploration,
all combined into a single
entity or trait logos.
The combination of logos and chaos
is what brings order into being.
That's what the story in genesis means.
It's not a empirical description
of the origin of objects.
It's a phenomenological description
of the origin of experience.
The idea of being that
without the piercing glance
of whatever consciousness is,
whatever the background of experience is,
the matrix chaos cannot
be conceptualized as real.
It takes the interplay between the
feminine principle chaos and the masculine
principle logos in order to produce being
now thoughts of substantial importance
when you give some consideration to the
fact that immediately in genesis,
after the establishment of livable order,
the day of the Yahuah identifies as
the individual human being with logos,
right made in God's image.
That's the essential
characteristic of the human being.
And what that means is that the
logos that operates in human beings,
which is this capacity to
make order out of chaos,
is identical to the principal that gives
rise to the cosmos from a mythological
perspective.
So it partakes of the day.
Eddie,
in a very direct sense in so far as being
itself is dependent on its operation.
Okay?
Now it's still possible to claim,
given that perspective that a story with
that sort of structure is superstitious
and then it doesn't bear any relationship
to what actually constitutes reality.
But you have to understand
that that story old as it is,
it's predicated on older stories and it's
on the ground that those older stories
established that our entire
concept of natural rights rests.
So if you believe that natural rights
have an existence that's more than merely
arbitrary,
the reason you believe that
is because they're predicate.
Those rights are predicated on the
ideas that are expressed in these myths.